du noyau à la liqueur à poissy c'est un
savoir ancestral à l'origine de famille
les duval créatrice du noyau blanc et
les dumont gardien de la recette du
noyau en bray qui fusionnent dans les
années 60 mais la liqueur apparaît au
dix septième siècle c'était dédié
notamment aux gens qui venaient acheter
sur le marché aux bestiaux de poissy qui
était à l'époque extrêmement réputé qui
venaient acheter leurs bêtes il y
consommer en fait cette liqueur c'était
vraiment la liqueur incontournable du
marché qu'il fallait boire au 105 rue du
général de gaulle en 10 ty et on m'a
sert depuis 1906 la recette n'a pas
changé depuis son élaboration
les alambics sont toujours là et sont au
travail en fonction des besoins
mais le secret de fabrication reste bien
gardé a toujours pour les liqueurs un
processus de fabrication il ya toujours
une base qui est commune c'est-à-dire
une macération qui peut être de
différents produits donc on sait les
amandons de noyau d'abricot qui sont
utilisés et donc il ya toujours une
macération de base est en fuite
on peut distiller ou pas donc là c'est
vraiment fonction de nos deux recettes
dans la région en fait fin du dix
septième siècle on avait déjà une grosse
implantation d'abricotiers sauvages qui
ne sont pas les mêmes c'est important de
le préciser que ce qu'on trouve sur nos
marchés actuels c'est vraiment une
variété spéciale qui s'était implanté
donc au tout début du xviie siècle et ça
a disparu
20 45 aujourd'hui les noyaux viennent du
pourtour méditerranéen la distillerie
produit environ trente mille bouteilles
chaque année ce patrimoine dévoile
quelques-uns de ses mystères le 24
juillet une visite sans modération
jusqu'à la dégustation